sharp contrasts are emerging in the
global battle with covid as another new
variant develops china where kova 19 is
thought to have originated is reporting
its first coronavirus-related death
since last january here in the u.s the
nation's second largest school district
los angeles is preparing to drop its
mask mandate the change comes as the
number of new covig cases in the u.s has
dropped dramatically over the past month
but the number of new cases globally has
climbed by eight percent within the last
week michael george is here with the
very latest good morning michael
michelle good morning as the covid cases
continue to drop here in the u.s both
pfizer and modern are asking the food
and drug administration to approve a
fourth dose of their vaccines staying
boosted will be increasingly important
as the new ba2 covet variant begins to
spread in this country
fourth covet vaccine doses are already
recommended by the centers for disease
control for some sick people the cdc
does recommend fourth doses for the
immunocompromised well it hasn't been of
course as you noted approved for others
pfizer wants its booster to be available
for people 65 and older while moderna
wants to give its fourth shot to all
adults even with nearly 65 percent of
the u.s population fully vaccinated
there remain millions of people who
haven't been vaccinated at all
we have reached a pivot point
how well we pivot
is on us all of us and so
if you ask me will things go well i'll
return the answer by saying
will everyone do their part talking with
the associated press yesterday health
and human services secretary javier
becerra again urged vaccinations for
more people before the highly contagious
ba2 variant hits hard and if everyone
does their part then yes if not
get ready because
this thing has taken us on a wild ride
covet is hard to tame and we've learned
kovit can throw any number of things at
us so get ready
we're still in the early stages with
ba.2 but the evidence so far shows that
it doesn't appear to be more severe than
omicron and research shows that the
current vaccines do offer good
protection against it jeff okay michael
thank you very much for more